it's a timeless story and I think that's
why it's always worked as a franchise in
many ways some there's something kind of
wonderful about the Watersafe scenario
that another species on this planet were
to become the alphas of our planet and
and I feel that has really stood the
test of time in the same way that you
know the trials of Hercules is still as
relevant now or a feeling to a modern
audience as it was in terms of the
mythology of that of that period so what
we've tried to do that is so very
different from the other films in the
franchise's is tell the story set in the
here and now it's a contemporary story
it deals with real-world science and
there is a certain amount of heightened
reality in terms of we're dealing with
an illness that has yet unfortunately to
find a cure but we're taking that idea
of something that is is that is created
for the good of mankind actually has
potentially the reverse effect it has
the potential to change lives
some things are meant to be changed
we're dealing with real lengths we're
dealing with real thrillers orangutangs
chimpanzees and and so to tell that
story about real aids again is so
different from the other films in the
franchise the other you know the other
aspects of the mythology and frankly
we've never had the technology to
achieve that and we never could have
used live apes and we never would have
wanted to use live Apes I think it would
have been a real cruel irony to tell the
story of the oppressed and use them and
exploit them so I'm really pleased that
we had the opportunity which two three
years ago we probably couldn't have
pulled this off and so it's a real first
in terms of cinema and being able to
tell the story a narrative driven
character driven story about a whole
other species and have human actors the
most important thing is that really
whenever you receive a script whenever
you get a script you read it and you
think do I want to do this story or not
and the whole of the technology that
will then enable you to shoot that movie
or play that part is it's kind of
secondary to anything so if it's like a
live-action movie or or you know movie
that involves performance capture you
don't think well I'll take on a role or
you know because it because it's it's
short in this particular way or it's a
3d movie or that you know people do
think for some weird reason performance
capture is it as genre and it's a tool
and that's the real really really
important thing to remember I mean
probably the reason that Rupert got
involved was certainly the reason I got
involved was the power of the written
word that and the power of the script
and it was an amazing origin story and a
beautifully crafted written character
Caesar goes on this incredible journey
from Venus innocent
who basically becomes a revolutionary
leader you know and it was it's in a
vastly different character to do that of
Kong say who is very much you know an
isolated lonely survivor past his prime
he's going to die nearly every day and
who actually connects with someone with
it with all of the human being this is
this is about this is about you know in
terms of playing the role it's a journey
from it from an innocence and a sense of
feeling love than nurtured and brought
up with people that knew that loved him
that almost like a child that that has
given a great start in life and then
Sonny reaching a point where he becomes
self-aware and realizes that in fact
he's some kind of freak and that he then
and then through no fault of his own but
yet no real fault of his own is then
incarcerated and Fernet aborted
what in effect is a heart the hardcore
prison and then has to deal with with
whether he is part of the tribe that are
in the prison or whether he's is easily
or how much to reject a humanity that
he's grown up with so it's it's a very
complex psychologically and emotionally
kind of complex role and so we between
us you know
the challenge was really to craft that
story and craft and be very specific to
each individual moment of their of the
journey of that character so that it
never felt and so Caesar never felt over
kind of anthropomorphize but-but-but-but
that he had to have this kind of extra
intelligence our whole kind of mo going
into making this film it's telling this
story was to sort of chart Caesars
evolution
and as a character but also as a species
you know as a representative of a
species that has deviated from you know
what he initially is which is a classic
archetype of chimpanzee into something
that is more evolved and to have the
opportunity to do that within a short
space of time with him just a you know a
finite number of years he's really
exciting from a storytelling point of
view because then you've got the
opportunity to see how he loves to see
in the same way that we as a species
have evolved through the discovery of
the Weir's or fire or all of the things
that have kind of sort of propelled our
civilization forward we try to do that
when we were talking we tried to think
okay what are the specific moments well
we see how Caesar grows more intelligent
how he grows more cognizance of the
world around him but at the same time
early on in the first act of the film he
remains an innocence he's sort of he's
John Merrick and the Elephant Man was
something like those frankerz that base
and and really the key for that was in
the eyes as far as I was concerned and
you know working with somebody like Andy
when you have the opportunity to work
with somebody who is incredibly
expressive as a performer and you know
how that can then translate into the
entity that is Caesar into this simian
entity that's the way and that's the
kind of portal into something that is
ultimately computer-generated but needs
to have a soul it was no it was no
coincidence that the first image that
was put out that represented this movie
was a very very standard lots of single
frame shot of Andy's performance with
the swivel of the eye and we didn't you
know that that came from Wetty that was
that was a very random you know we
didn't even know they came to La Jolla
Terry from weatr flew to LA with a
surprise for us and this was four months
in supposed and he said I've got a
surprise for you and we were expecting
our first ape shot I think six weeks
later and he projected it for us and
everybody just watched it on loop over
and over again we couldn't get over
I mean whether are without question and
a world world leaders in terms of as a
team who not only understands
technically how to create a digital I
and how it you know opens up in the
pupil dilates and how moisture affects
it and like the frack topic what they're
brilliant at doing is interpreting
actors performance so they're very
they're very loyal and very true you
know they remain very true to the
storytelling they know that drama is is
king in the world of visual effects you
know and they're not about showing off
their about they're about really serving
the moment and it was great lesson for
me for somebody who come into
performance capture for the first time
and really having to understand it or at
least get a handle you know working with
Andy obviously I went naught to 60 in
about seven days but I but Joe said
something that was really great to hear
which is he said just make sure that you
get the performance don't think for a
second that we can create that before us
we don't get it you know you haven't got
it and that's you know that's that's
that's the mark of a of a creative mind
as well as a technician that's all
tractors haven't done it before and they
think because performance can't it's
performance capture I might have to over
animate or kind of pull my face around a
bit more or don't you know get through
something to get through this technology
but actually the reverse is true you
have to play it as if it were a live
action big close-up when we get into the
Edit where Andy performed on Seth in
front of the camera is basically what we
cut and then what we cut and what we
shape we have a cut that is Andy in his
motion capture suit and that is then
transferred to wetter and that's what
they were from they don't recreate it
they don't you know keyframe it they
basically work on that and if they if
they were to deviate then we'd be in
trouble
because it wouldn't cut together